[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 7 novembre bienvenue dans
le 78 sur tv78 voici tout de suite les
titres de cette
édition après 9 jours d'attente dans le
port du Havre c'est enfin partie la
Transat jacqu Vabre a démarré ce matin
pour la catégorie imoka le départ de la
course de voile transatlantique avait dû
être reporté en raison des tempêtes
Karan et Domingos parmi les participants
qui ont pris la direction de la
Martinique deux ivelinois Louis Burton
et Eric Bellon la map terrain vague
faite cette année ses 15 ans d'existence
à gui en cours à map pour Association
pour le Maintien d'une Agriculture
paysane en clair des consommateurs se
réunissent pour acheter des produits
frais et de saison en circuit court à
des producteurs locaux un mode de
fonctionnement qui profite à tous
explication les Yvelines à la sauce
américaine le département compte
plusieurs clubs où il est possible de
pratiquer la country une danse qui
rassemble et qui est accessible à tous
les âges cette passion a réuni près de
150 adeptes à Plaisir samedi dernier à
l'occasion d'un bal concert organisé par
l'association cowboy at dancers et puis
l'invité du 78 en 2e partie d'émission
focus ce soir sur le concours MDRS des
maisons de retraite pas comme les autres
il récompense des épades et des
résidences seniores dans quatre
catégories l'objectif notamment donner
une autre image de ces établissements au
grand public dans les ivelines quatre
sites TR sites figurent parmi les
sélectionnés dans dont la maison de
famille les e viv à Saint-Rémi les
chevreuses et nous recevrons tout à
l'heure le directeur de cet
établissement dans le 78 mais d'abord on
va faire le point sur les informations
du jour dans les
ivelines et c'est avec vous Mathilde
Francou bonsoir bonsoirgor et on débute
avec cette information sportive après
plus d'une semaine d'attente c'est enfin
parti pour les bateaux imoka de la
Transa jackvabre et oui après 9 jours
d'attente en raison des mauvais mavaises
conditions climatiqu lié aux tempêtes
Kiran et Domingos les imoka ont enfin
pris le départ du Havre ce matin
direction la Martinique conséquence pour
cette catégorie le tracé a été réduit
pour cette 30e édition les bateaux
laisseront à tribor l'île de Santa Maria
parmi les 80 skipppers de ivelinois
Laurent bolitin Louis Burton pour sa 7e
transat fait équipe avec Davy baudar sur
bureau Vallé de son côté le versaillais
Éric Bellon pour sa 2uxè participation
est accompagné du skiper Martin le pape
sur standers One à 17h bureau valallleet
pointé à la 4e position de son côté
standers One est 22e on suivra bien sûr
la traversée de nos skipers yvelinois un
coup de tonner à présent dans le monde
du football yvelinois oui c'est une
information de nos confrères du Parisien
Laurent perlad n'est plus l'entraîneur
du FC Versailles il a été écarté de
l'équipe en début de semaine Laurent
perlad était arrivé cet été sur le banc
versailla en remplacement du Brésilien
Chris conséquence sans doute du bilan
médiocre du club 3 victoire seulement en
12 matchs de championnat de National les
Versaillais sont actuellement 12e du
classement ils ont de plus été éliminés
le weekend dernier de la Coupe de France
Laurent Perlade est remplacé par son
adjoint Grégory vigal le FC Versailles
affrontera à nîes au stade de jeanoin
pour le compte de la 13e journée ce
vendredi on devrait pouvoir en 2024
ma'il circuler sur les autoroutes en
flux libre la sanf société des autor du
Nord et de l'Est de la France a détaillé
le calendrier cet après-midi qu'en
est-il dans les ivelines de autoroutes
sont concernées Grégori il s'agit de la
13 et de LA1 qui relie la région
parisienne à la Normandie parmi les 14
sit trois sont dans le département le
site de Montesson le diffuseur N6 de
chamboursy et le site de bûchelet
l'objectif supprimer les barrières de
péage pour ne plus marquer d'arrêt et
payer de façon dématérialisée depuis mai
2023 des équipements ont déjà été posés
sur les sites comme les fondations des
portiques des glissères et de marquage
au sol les sites de chamboursy et de
Mont son devrai recevoir leur portique
avant Noël 2023 interrogé sur l'impact
des travaux sur les automobilistes la
SANEF se veut rassurante la société mise
sur la communication avant les
éventuelles fermetures des travaux
principalement nocturnes mais aussi du
personnel pour aider à payer en décembre
2024 les 14 sites devraient être en
service on termine Mathilde avec une
information qui va intéresser les
amateurs de sport mais aussi les
demandeurs d'emploi Pôle Emploi Paris
2024 et Saint-Quentin en organise le 21
novembre une grande opération de
recrutement des milliers de postes sont
à pourvoir en vue des Jeux Olympiques
dans les domaines de l'hôtellerie la
restauration le tourisme mais aussi la
sécurité ou encore l'événementiel une
quarantaine d'entreprises se réuniront
au Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin
en nielin plusieurs types de contrats
seront proposés accompagnés de formation
ce rendez-vous est ouvert à tous et une
attente une attention particulière sera
accordée aux demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée et aux personnes en
situation de handicap une préinscription
en ligne est obligatoire pour participer
à l'événement rendez-vous sur le site
internet
cqutineveline.fr merci Mathilde et si
vous aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les ivelines n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news 15 ans d'existence pour terrain
vague à guencour c'est une association
qui est une AMAP elle œuvre pour le
maintien d'une agriculture paysane en
Île-de-France il existe près de 500 de
ces structures plus de 2200 en France
leur principe et des producteurs locaux
proposent aux adhérents leurs produits
frais en vente directe une façon pour le
consommateur de savoir d'où vient son
alimentation et d'assurer par la même
occasion à l'agriculteur des revenus
stables explication avec Julien
Leroi isab ça va ça va ouais ça va alors
grand panier ou panier des denrés de la
ferme prennent place sur les étales dans
la MAP terrainvague huit producteurs
locaux proposent leurs marchandises en
vente directe fruits pain ou œufs issus
de l'agriculture biologique sont proposé
chaque semaine des colis gourmands
récupérés par la cinquantaine
d'adhérents dans l'espace yvmant à Guill
en cour on a des produits très frais les
légumes qu'on m qu'on récolte le jeudi
soir ils ont été ramassés pour la
plupart le jeudi matin et on connaît
aussi en quelque sorte leur histoire on
mange pas du poulet on mange le poulet
de Charles on mange pas du fromage de
chèvre on mange le fromage de chèvre de
Claudie une consommation responsable
loin de l'image de la grande
distribution dans cette Association pour
le Maintien d'une Agriculture paysane
pas de fraise ni de tomate en hiver de
paniers hebdomadaires de 13 ou 22 €
doivent être récupérés chacun est
composé au rythme des saisons on se
laisse un peu surprendre parce que le
maréchf va nous proposer et ensuite bah
ça nous oblige à à cuisiner des légumes
qu'on avait peut-être pas le l'habitude
de cuisiner discussion sur les problèmes
de récolte ou les intempéries à travers
l'association une solidarité économique
se met en place pour soutenir les
agriculteurs chaque adhérent s'engage à
acheter à l'avance une partie de sa
récolte la garantie de revenus plus
pérenne moi les AMAP aujourd'hui à la
ferme ça représente 35 % de mes
débouchés je suis assurer sur ces 35 %
ça va me permettre de financer la
nourriture parce que 75 % de la
nourriture moi je la finance après la
moisson quoi donc j'ai un stock de
nourriture pour l'année grâce aux zap ça
va financer la nourriture de tous les
poulets quoi distribution des paniers ou
animation chaque membre doit donner de
son temps et s'acquitter d'une adhésion
annuelle de 15 € plus de 60 de ces
associations sont présente dans le
département des Yvelines de son côté la
MAP terrainvag à Guille en cours faite
cette année c'est 15
ans on ouvre une page culture à présent
dans le
un nom qui ne vous dit peut-être rien
Noël Coppel et pourtant ce peintre fut
l'une des figures marquantes sous le
règne de Louis XIV pour rendre hommage à
cet artiste méconnu du grand public le
château de Versailles lui consacre une
exposition au Grand Trianon elle est à
voir jusqu'au 28 janvier Anne-Sophie
mouquer et Julien
Leroi il était un contemporain de Louis
XIV Noël coapel artiste peintre du 17e
siècle né en 1628 et mort en 1707 il
laisse derrière lui une longue carrière
de 79 ans tout au long de sa vie il
mettra son talent au service du Roi
Soleil et de l'église c'était vraiment
un des peintres importants qui a la
carrière académique euh qu'apprécie tout
grand peintre du 17e il pein son morceau
de réception pour rentrer à l'Académie
puis est professeur puis directeur de
l'Académie de France à Rome puis
directeur même de l'Académie royale de
peinture et de sculpture à Paris donc
une très belle carrière d'un point de
vue officiel fondateur d'une dynastie de
peintrre Noël coapel brille dans
plusieurs domaines peinture sur cheval
et peinture murale ce qui fera de lui
l'un des peintres les plus affluants de
son siècle c'est sa rencontre avec
Charles Herard qui le fera travailler au
château il s'occupera essentiellement
des grands décors notamment ceux de la
chambre du roi lorsqu rard Charles hard
aura été écarté par Charles lebrin on
l'Envoy comme directeur de l'Académie de
France à Rome comme ça bien loin de de
Paris et de Versailles coapel va passer
sous la la houlette si je puis dire de
Charles lebrin et aura deux salons à
décorer dans le grand appartement du roi
du Parlement de Bretagne à Rennes au
demeur Royal c'est seulement à la fin de
sa vie qui s'occupera des Invalides
certaines de ces uvres ont aujourd'hui
disparu il reste néanmoins plusieurs
grands décors comme le tableau la rosé
ici c'est un des tableau de la série
d'Hercule il reçoit cette commande en
1688 il mettra beaucoup de temps à la
peindre à tel point qu'en fait
l'ensemble ne sera pas mis en place au
Trianon sous bois qui est une des ailes
du Grand Trianon des tableaux
d'exception pour un palais d'exception
exposés dans un décor qu'il a lui-même
réalisé à travers une sélection de 90
œuvres uniques l'exposition retrace
l'histoire de la peinture de l'artiste
dans un décor Royal celle durera
jusqu'au 28 janvier
2024 les ivelines réservoir de talent
humoristique certains grand nom de la
scène ont fait leur début ici dans le
département pour que les nouveaux
talents puissent tester des artistes de
houd ont lancé en 2018 le 78 Comédy club
aujourd'hui il en est à sa 6e saison
changement de lieu changement de formule
le point avec l'un de ses cofondateurs
interrogés par Mélanie
[Musique]
poet
c'est une scène ouverte qui a sur la
commune de Oudan le principe c'est que
les artistes ont 7 à 10 minutes voilà
pour faire une petite prestation devant
le public et on accueille tout types
d'artistes que ce soit des artistes
amateurs professionnels
semi-professionnels voilà c'est ouvert à
tous lancer les jeunes un petit peu qui
ont envie qui sont de la région et qui
ont pas forcément encore envie on va
dire de se lancer sur les scènes
parisiennes qui a envie de se tester un
peu en province comme on dit c'était au
niveau social et culturel à Oudan de
créer quelque chose un projet et que on
est entre guillemets un public d'habitué
que les gens se se retrouve
régulièrement c'est très simple c'est
partout pareil tu colles ta carte contre
la machine et au bout d'une demi-onde la
machine fait bip mais il y en a qui perd
facilement patience dès que la machine
plus de 0,8 secondes à piper il passe en
mode vibreur
gen
[Musique]
on a retrouvé un nouveau lieu donc qui
est le restaurant la poularde à Oudan
depuis de saisons on a réduit le nombre
d'artistes à 6 plutôt que
et euh tout simplement pour que voilà la
deuxème partie soit un peu plus légère
et parce qu'on sait qu'on est le jeudi
soir quand même l'entrée est totalement
gratuite on a la réservation obligatoire
euh pour qu'on sache le nombre de
personnes qui se présentent mais voilà
ensuite il y a une sortie chapeau ce qui
nous permet de de rémunérer les
différents artistes au
[Musique]
chapeau comme tous les mardis une salle
du territoire vous donne trois raisons
d'aller voir sa prochaine date ce soir
la MERIS à trrappe nous parle de sa
soirée 100 % féminine du 25 novembre
avec deux humoristes à l'affiche Rosa
burürstein et Tania Dutel pour vous
convaincre c'est franciscoostar au micro
de Mathilde Francou bonjour je suis
Francis costar l'ami des stars directeur
de la murise et aujourd'hui aujourd'hi
je vais vous donner trois bonnes raisons
de venir sur la soirée du 25 novembre à
la
[Musique]
murise la première le S raison c'est la
journée de lutte contre les violence
fait aux femmes et là c'est important
d'y être et de montrer notre soutien à
cette noble cause deuxième chose deux
artistes qui sont en train de monter
monter monter grimper dans l'humour tan
Dutel et Rosa Bernstein 3è raison mais
ce soir-là vous avez rien d'autre à
faire c'est chez nous qu' faut être à la
merurise le 25 novembre att trrappe on
compte sur vous les tampons c'est blindé
de pesticides c'est pour rendre le coton
plus blanc déjà c'est hyper
raciste quand vous embrouillez avec
quelqu'un que vous connaissez pas dans
la rue votre réparti elle est meilleure
après dans votre tête quand vous êtes
chez
vous et puis de la danse de la danse
country qui compte de plus en plus
d'adeptes en France 4 millions de
Français de plus de 18 ans l'ont déjà
pratiqué au moins une fois dans leur vie
et pour s'initier plusieurs clubs dans
les evvelines sont disponible pour
pratiquer justement cette country l'un
de cowboy dancers basé à plaisir qui
organisait la semaine dernière une
après-midi balle et concer même samedi
dernier on va regarder tout de suite le
reportage de Clara de
[Musique]
Frutos
ambiance à l'américaine en plein cœur de
plaisir ce jour-là ils sont près de 150
passionnés munis de leur chapeau et de
leur santiague pour danser la countterie
pour les accompagner les musiciens de
rocking chair c'est le partage entre les
élèves entre tout le monde nous on est
bénévole et on partage notre savoir et
on partage toutes les soirées ensemble
et ça c'est génial celle qui est à
l'initiative de ce rendez-vous c'est
elle Lili Levallois véritable enfant des
western elle a créé cowboy ad dancer en
2009 pour partager sa passion
aujourd'hui l'association compte 52
adhérents a des gens qui viennent de
chartre aussi qui viennent de toute la
région parisienne du 95 du 60 de partout
ça plaît énormément on commence jeune et
on finit on a j'ai eu des personnes qui
avaient 78 ans jusqu'à 78 ans et des
jeunes de 6 ans donc vous voyez tous les
âges tous les âges se retrouvent autour
de la dance country une activité que
tout le monde peut pratiquer c'est
l'ambiance les amis ben on fait
travailler la tête on fait travailler
les jambes bah de la joie parce que
c'est et en plus on a un petit groupe de
copains donc c'est bien franchement
cette dynamique et si vous voulez bah
bouger venez ici depuis plusieurs années
la ce suscite un véritable engouement
selon un sondage hiop publié en 2019 4
millions de personnes de plus de 18 ans
l'ont déjà a pratiqué au moins une fois
en club laise ça présente une certaine
liberté quand même voilà c'est la
liberté la conviabilité et puis
connaître du monde voilà c'est comme une
famille si vous aussi vous souhaitez
découvrir la country cowboy addcer
propose une adhésion de 170
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
€ avant de retrouver l'invité du 78 coup
d'œil à vos prévisions météo de
demain de la grisaille au menu de votre
matinée de mercredi dans les Yvelines il
fera 8°gr dans la partie centre du
territoire 9°gr au nord et 7° dans la
moitié sud l'après-midi la pluie se
joint à la partie ça devrait également
souffler fort des rafales de vent
pourront atteindre les 65 km/h côté
température il fera en moyenne de 11 à
12°gr dans les ivelines et demain un
mercredi 8 novembre nous fait on les j
frroids tout de suite l'invité du
[Musique]
78 des maisons de retraite pas comme les
autres le concours MDRS distingue des
épas des résidences senior à travers
toute la France 68 établissements sont
sélectionnés pour cette 6e édition du
concours et le tout dans quatre
catégories dans cette liste on retrouve
trois sites dans les zelines on va aller
voir afficher la Villa des aînés à
bonière sursène pour la thématique
incroyable talent épad Corian
Clairefontaine dans la catégorie mission
1 possible éepad et la Maison des
familles lesau viives à Saint-Rémi les
chevreus pour une équipe formidable
éepad et pour désigner les vainqueurs
vous avez jusqu'au 30 novembre pour
voter pour vos établissements préférés
c'est via le site qui va s'afficher ça y
est il s'affiche en bas de l'écran
bonsoir Jean-Baptiste Morau bonsoir vous
êtes-vous le directeur de la Maison des
familles les EAU vives situés à à
Saint-Rémi les chevreuses alors lesp je
le disais est sélectionné dans ce
concours dans la catégorie une équipe
formidable le fait de figurer dans cette
sélection ça vous fait quoi alors c'est
à chaque fois c'est une fierté c'est la
4e année consécutive dans lequelle on on
figure dans cette sélection on a
remporté du coup il y a 2 ans le le
trophée et et du coup chaque année c'est
un challenge pour les équipe de d'être à
nouveau sélectionné dans dans ce
concours MDRS qui récompense des
initiatives originales dans notre
secteur on va en parler dans dans un
instant et vous aviez été primé aussi
dans cette catégorie là c'était pas les
mêmes catégories donc ça change chaque
année alors présentez-nous lespad un peu
la carte d'identité combien de résidents
combien de personnes compose le
personnel alors du coup cet épad donc
qui à saintréis les chevreuses accueille
86 résidents et on voilà il y a une
équipe de à peu près 70 personnes alors
dans votre argumentaire sur le site du
concours MDRS vous dites être un lieu
d'accueil bienveillant convivial est
ouvert sur l'extérieur et l'actualité
votre établissement se va être un lieu
de partage bah parlez-nous de ces
valeurs et est-ce que c'est aussi pour
ça votre avis que ça fait la différence
pour être sélectionné de nouveau cette
année alors ce qui est de toute façon ce
qui est important dans dans notre
secteur c'est
véritablement que lespad soit une vraie
équipe du directeur jusque à la cuisine
aux agents techniques aux agents hôtel
et au
soignant c'est cette magie cette
symbiose qui fait qu'il a un esprit et
un véritable esprit d'équipe pour
prendre en charge les résidents et sur
des projets comme ça quand on chacun se
décloisonne de son propre métier et on
on va toujours plus loin et et c'est ce
qui nous motive chaque année et tout au
long de l'année de faire des projets
originaux pour déjà pour les résidents
pour les divertir parce que c'est un
lieu de vie et qu'ils ont besoin de
divertissement euh et pour aussi pour
les équipes pourager pour partager des
moments conviviaux parce que c'est avant
tout un lieu de vie et qu'on peut pas
imaginer un lieu de vie sans moment
conviviaux sans faire la fête et nous
c'est un peu notre ADN alors un projet
justement à l'occasion de la coupe du
monde de rugby qui s'est achevé il y a
peu bon on va pas parler des résultats
de de la France qui peuvent encore faire
mal à à certains mais vous avez en tout
cas réalisé une vidéo qui met en scène
résident et personnel de l'épat vous
avez revisité un match de rugby
justement entre le 15 de France et les
black de la Nouvelle-Zélande on va
regarder tout de suite un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
extrait
al rafu Viiv c'est le nom de de cette
vidéo bah pourquoi avoir fait ce clip
c'est l'idée de donner une image plus
positive des épades alors on
avait pendant le
confinement les des joueurs de football
avaient fait des vidéos pour montrer
chez eux enfin pour s'amuser et cetera à
cette époque là on avait déjà fait une
vidéo avec un ballon on s'est dit c'est
la Coupe du monde de rugby on va prendre
le ballon de rugby et on va recréer
aussi une vidéo pour pour du coup pour
pour vous l'objectif c'est c'est de
provoquer c'est de créer de buzz c'est
de faire sourire sur un monde où du coup
souvent on ne sourit pas et de montrer
que il s passe voilà des des choses
sympathiques et originales et qu'on s'y
amuse mais justement c'est l'objectif du
concours MDRS c'est de présenter une
autre image des maisons de retraite au
grand public mais en quoi c'est
important justement de donner cette
autre image peut-être de changer les
regards sur les maisons de retraite
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui l'image
sur notre secteur Est est pas très bon
c'est à cause du livre Les fossoyurs qui
est sorti en 2022 qui dépignait
justement des des cas de maltraitance
mais c'est plus compliqué que ça euh
c'est vraiment c'est un secteur en crise
pour multiples raisons et aujourd'hui la
meilleure manière de de de répondre
c'est de montrer les actions positives
et et de garder pour les résidents et
puis aussi pour les corateurs qui sont
aujourd'hui courageux de d'être toujours
engagés dans un secteur qui est
difficile euh de de fédérer tout le
monde autour de projet de convivialité
de plaisir et et qui qui se transmet en
fait le le c'est pendant le covid le le
virus se transmettait mais là le bonheur
en fait il se transmet aussi et c'est
important de le partager et que les
sourires se communiquent le monde de du
rugby tout le monde n'est pas forcément
passionné mais euh de s'amuser en
revanche tout le monde y a adhéré ils
ont été très vite volontaires les
résidents ils sont toujours très
volontaires pour s'amuser et puis pour
partager avec les équipes des
moments des moments sympas et ils sont
ils sont toujours partants et les
retours que vous avez eu sur la vidéo
les retours sont sont excellents on a
dans le monde du rugby sur dans dans le
sud de dans le Sud-Ouest
euh la vidéo a été énormément partagée
on a eu beaucoup de messages positifs
qui évidemment encourag
les les équipes à continuer et les
résidents c'est pour eux c'est et c'est
quelque chose de de flatteur qui peuvent
aussi ils en parlent avec leur famill
voilà en fait ils existent ils existent
il retrouvent un statut social à travers
du coup un sujet vraiment d'actualité
qui a la Coupe du monde de rugby en
France et vous parliez de cette image
négatif qu'il faut changer pour pour ces
maisons de retraite juste un chiffre à
donné fin 2019 plus de 700000 personnes
fréquentaient un établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgés c'est
un chiffre qui était en augmentation par
rapport aux années précédentes c'estàd
qu'avec le vieillissement de la
population c'est c'est c'est une
solution c'est ces maisons de de
retraite les demandes sont sont accrues
pour vous alors les les demandes de
toute façon avec le vieillissement de la
population ne vont faire que s'accroître
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
qu'il existe des dispositifs que ça soit
à domicile ou en institution qui
permettent aux personnes de pouvoir
choisir en fonction de leur niveau de
dépendance et en fonction de des soins
ou de leur projet de vie
et l'objectif c'est que tout le monde a
le choix et en fonction de de de son
choix de pouvoir retrouver un établi qui
correspond à leurs attentes et bien sûr
que les épades sont sont importants dans
cette solution aujourd'hui de euh et et
de cette perspective de de
vieillissement de la population c'est
quoi les avantages pour vous des éepad
l'avantage c'est avant tout la sécurité
euh ce sont des établissements où il y a
du personnel soignant 24 he sur
24 on n' pas de rupture sur sur cette
prise en charge de de soins par rapport
des fois à domicile où c'est aujourd'hui
plus compliqué et et puis surtout c'est
c'est un lieu de vie avec avec des
nouvelles connaissances avec des
nouvelles activités et on on a beaucoup
de gens qui retrouvent des amis qui
recréent du tissu social alors que chez
eux ils avaient pu être isolés et c'est
pas forcément pour toutes les bourses
parce que les tarifs sont assez élevés
au niveau mensuel alors évidemment il y
a il y a des établissements très
différents qui correspondent aussi des
fois en fonction des des des des j'envie
dire des revenus évidemment des des gens
qui cherchent un établissement et aussi
des projets de la localisation parce que
c'est souvent le prix dépend aussi du du
tarif immobilier lo du du terrain ou de
la ville dans lequelle l'établissement
est implanté revenons au concours pour
une dernière question les personnes je
disais ont jusqu'au 30 novembre pour
voter pour votre établissement dans la
catégorie une équipe formidable il faut
pour se faire aller donc sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran bah tout
simplement pourquoi voter pour vous pour
soutenir les équipes qui du coup
aujourd'hui sont engagés qui se pour
pour le plaisir des résidents et puis
aussi bien sûr bah pour les résidents la
France n'a pas gagné mais les vives
peuvent encore gagner merci
Jean-Baptiste Morau je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur de la Maison des
familles les vives à Saint-Rémi les
Chevreuse et dans ce concours MDRS deux
autres établissements dans les Yvelines
figurent parmi les sélectionnés vous les
voyez s'afficher la Villa des aîné à
bonir sur scène pour la thématique
incroyable talent épad et Corian
Clairefontaine dans la catégorie mission
impossible et pad voilà c'est la fin du
78 merci de votre fidélité demain
nouvelle édition vous avez rendez-vous
avec Mathilde Francou quant à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver dès
jeudi belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78